you
so today I'm going to talk a little bit
about home automation with Python 3
disclaimer for anybody hoping to see a
whole bunch of Python or Python 3
there's actually not gonna be a lot of
that sorry this is mainly because
there's a whole bunch of prerequisites
to home automation way before we get to
where there would actually be some
Python don't worry we'll get there this
is a short talk though not a complete
talk otherwise the other entire half of
it would be all the Python 3 maybe part
2 later so our short agenda tonight we
got some overview of home automation a
case for open source and things we can
do with our snazzy home automation but
first it's really useful to ask of
course what is home automation I so here
we have a few different easy examples of
it everybody needs to automate their cat
feeder for when there are away so you
have an automated cat feeder and then of
course since everybody has 36 port
Ethernet switches sitting around on
their tables you can wire that in and of
course your cat feeder should be on the
Internet how else would it be hacked to
have people send spam some other
wonderful examples which is actually
more we're going to talk about so I
don't think everybody wants to build
these i we have the typical smart home
you got screens all over the place you
never have too many screens that's why
we always carry one around in our pocket
as well dimmers we got water heaters you
got locks depending on how daring you
are who doesn't want a computer
controlling whether or not you can get
into your house and then of course down
here we have all sorts of little things
that are apparently on Wi-Fi which also
terrifies me so yeah what could ever go
wrong with all of these little devices
surely there would not be any problems
with this whatsoever
because everybody needs their smart
refrigerator to expose our gmail logins
now what I think is particularly awesome
about this example is the related right
here we got like welcome to the smart
home of horror security holes in your
smart hubs your router gateway for
hackers I don't know like if I came
across this page and I was like oh I
can't wait to hook my home up to the
internet this page would make me go oh
hell no so it's really important to
remember in light of this that the
Internet of Things is not the same as
home automation this is really critical
and everybody seems to confuse these
they seem to think oh well and also i'll
admit lots of people look at all those
neat little smart this smart that that's
all on IndieGoGo or Kickstarter and your
sneakers are going to have IP addresses
and everything's going to be on the
Internet I'm not a big fan of the
Internet of Things my things should
actually not be on the Internet that's
my strange little concept home
automation doesn't actually have
anything to do with that people have
been automating homes for a really long
time they've been making all sorts of
stuff happened way before anybody
thought well sure I want my front door
on the internet because of course that
would not be a problem so I don't want
to spend too much time talking about all
of these things that are on the internet
with your smart fridge and all this
other stuff I didn't pull up the article
by the way but one of my other favorite
ones again smart fridge smart fridge got
hacked there's an entire group of these
sending spam emails so that that's just
fantastic but ideally we don't want
things in our house on the internet at
least i don't i want them very far from
the internet or at least a layer removed
so ideally when I look at devices and
think about what in my house could be
automated or could be giving me more
feedback on what it's doing
well first off I want to look at non
Wi-Fi things so on that front we have a
few different prerequisites here so the
top to hear all three of these are
different forms of communication the top
two are very similar so z-wave and
z-wave plus if nobody's heard of it it's
a very low power thing it's intended for
devices in a home like outlets wall
switches dimmer switches there's locks
that work on on z-wave and zigbee the
other nice thing about these if you wire
in a switch somewhere they extend the
network bo z-wave and zigbee are mesh
network topologies so as you wire in
more of these around your house your
range expands and everything will
automatically try to find the shortest
route back to the controller which we'll
get to here in a minute z-wave is 1 i'm
going to focus on none of this and
that's mainly because one company holds
the license and pass into it at the
moment which is sigma designs and
they're the only ones that can
manufacture chip now that sounds kind of
bad until you realize that there's so
many different things using zigbee which
is an IEE standard there is no standard
on the chips and as I don't know if
anybody's use other things which were
based on standards but sometimes you
find out that this thing on the standard
doesn't want to talk to that thing
supposedly on the same standard but they
did it slightly differently that happens
with zigbee a lot more than z-wave so
I've generally tried to pull up z-wave
type things and you could find lots of
these if you actually just search on
amazon com for z-wave you'll be amazed
at the amount of things that you can
just go ahead and plop onto a z-wave
network and then of course our last one
bluetooth LE a bunch of people are
familiar with this this is the
low-energy Bluetooth standard it's on
the newer phones if anybody's used apple
home kit a bunch of home kit devices
generally either use Wi-Fi or they use
bluetooth LE
the main problem with something like
Bluetooth le over the other two is that
Bluetooth le is not a mesh network and
you need to make sure that the main
controller trying to talk to it is
within range so you can easily get a lot
of range problems with Bluetooth le
devices this really matters a lot if
this is a sensor a rain sensor
especially like a door lock you don't
want to find out that your door lock is
not too far away from the thing trying
to control it I don't turn your head
sideways all at once this is the only
way I can fit a bunch of these lon this
is just an example of some of the things
that are all z-wave so you can just see
some of the different things that you
can pick up you got went door and window
sensors here door bells garage door
openers that lights leds I don't know if
anybody's used Philips hue bulbs those
are fun they can do a whole bunch of
different party things with colors they
can also do different degrees of warmth
if you want softer light or brighter
light with more blue in it you could
choose we've got a whole bunch of
different z-wave things that we can do
now of course as you might have noticed
as I said when you have all of your home
devices and you have switches and all
this other stuff speaking z-wave how do
you actually get any of it to do
anything right because it's not on the
internet all these devices are talking
to each other using a standard z-wave or
or zigbee you need something to control
them and this is where you hear the term
your Smart Hub so this was in the other
article in the related smart hubs
getting hacked we'll go over a little of
that too these are three popular smart
hub models essentially what they all
have in common is they all speak either
z-wave or zigbee generally both the
concept is you get one of these devices
you put it in your home somewhere you
put it on your Wi-Fi network or some way
that your phone could talk to it
and then it talks all the other devices
that are using Z waiver zigbee in your
home that one I believe is the smart
things hub by Samsung now we got a wink
hub and we have Vera down here these are
several of the most popular ones these
were sort of your more turnkey type
things where if you want to just go and
buy things that are this works with so
and so that might be a good option there
is one problem here though this is kind
of long this is from one of the
wonderful reviews on the smart things
hub why things always had his quirks
over the past few weeks it's gotten so
bad it's become a complete nuisance
routines are failing constantly woke up
to a cold house the thermostat failed to
trigger a dark house the lights failed
to turn on and a blaring alarm when
opening the door the alarm failed to
disarm when we arrived home I hit damn
home routine and again the alarm sounded
upon entering for reasons unknown in the
house was dark uh I read something like
this and I generally run screaming the
other way there is no way in hell I want
this in charge of anything in my house
and I definitely don't want to hook up a
loud alarm to it that just seems like a
really bad idea now to be fair when I
originally read this two months ago this
was a one-star review he has since
changed to five stars because apparently
Samsung rolled out updates over the
cloud automatically to his device which
updated itself and then the issues went
away so he's been doing great for four
months now the next paragraph says
hopefully it'll keep on going this way
because they might do another update
in case that wasn't a good case for open
source as I just brought up there we
have the issue what if the smart hubs
proprietary software has a problem I
don't know if I'm gonna have something
in my home that's going to be talking to
all these are devices I generally want
to know what's going on with it inside I
want to be able to see at least are
things getting better or worse if
there's a firmware version or whatever
that works I sure as heck don't want
them to send me an automatic update that
then breaks my house that would really
suck so I wanted to set some of this
stuff up so I'm going through looking at
this and I go oh I can't I can't go this
way I'm kind of familiar with open
source software surely we have some open
source software but does home automation
that doesn't involve using proprietary
hubs that run who knows what software
that's updated by other people that may
or may not care as much about what's
happening in your house hopefully more
but you never know so here are a few we
have open have is a java-based one we
have osa which is windows only in
c-sharp we have home assistant in Python
3 spoiler alert i'm going to talk about
more than later because it's Python 3
open remote which is in Java and then
there's some others so I looked through
all of these when I was trying to figure
out what to do because I was like well I
don't want to use something where some
other companies rolling updates to it
over the cloud that may or may not break
things and where if it's not working I
can't go in and take a look at why it's
not working I I generally like being
able to do that now even though I do run
some open source software all admit for
for a fact i have never gone into the
linux kernel when something has gone
wrong with linux how many other people
here use linux on occasion right and
anytime you've ever had a problem you
immediately go i'm going to look at the
source code right probably not
any of us probably don't even know see
and we definitely don't know what the
hell's going on inside the Linux kernel
the fun thing about these is they're
doing a lot less the codes a lot smaller
you can actually get into this for
example on home assistant which I'm
going to talk a bit more about in Python
3 the core of it is only about 600 lines
of code you can actually read this and
understand what's going on and that was
really meaningful to me now of course
even once you have this rolling you have
it all running what are you going to run
it on right I showed you earlier we have
these hubs we need something to run this
on and that's where we have an open
source smart hub so we got a Raspberry
Pi hear that little thing stuck into it
is a z-wave USB stick you can buy those
about 40 bucks so you got a raspberry pi
3 and then you got about 90 bucks you're
done you're ready to automate your home
depending on how paranoid you are you
could turn off the Wi-Fi on the
Raspberry Pi or just not even plug it
into the internet after you configure it
it doesn't have to be on the internet
let's talk about home assistant the
current requirements for Python 3.4
points you are better this is actually a
recent one earlier i think is only 3.4 i
might have had something to do with
bumping it up two three four two there's
a whole bunch of integrations there you
can make it talk to your Philips hue
lights if you have a plex media server
can talk to that it's like two access
points you might be surprised why you
would care about that very active and
friendly community regular release
schedule so this is a fun little piece
of software to use let's look at a few
of the things we can do really quick so
this is right off the website and you'll
see that it's more than home automation
I might have actually been a joking a
little bit when I said home automation
because you don't actually have to
automate things because you'll notice
the first category here is observing
homelessness and contract the state of
all the devices in your home it could
talk to your nest your hue your plex
your if you have a verra or one of the
other smart hubs it can actually talk to
that
can talk to your netgear you can
actually have it give you a histogram of
what devices are going on and off your
Wi-Fi network throughout the day so you
can observe a decent amount of stuff
just that's happening at home you can
use his control things you don't have to
automate everything and then of course
you can do automation as well now wait a
second you can observe this is where I
got really interested I'm not ready to
have my front door on the on any
computer I just don't trust computers
enough I've worked with them too long to
trust them to open my front door this is
what my current panel looks like on my
home assistant I got my wife's ipad and
iphone there the all devices stuff is
being pulled for and comes off an access
point the history of it is all tracked
this all goes into a SQLite database
again all of this is Python you can add
to it extended easily you have your own
data monitoring tool that integrates
with all sorts of other things that you
might not have considered home automated
stuff or smart home stuff but you can
actually pull it all together it queries
wunderground there's a one of the local
cotati ones we have microclimates up in
the north bay so generally anything any
of the big guys that give me the weather
are always wrong because they're not in
the same area I have some Philips hue
lights that I put in so I could turn on
the living room lights I have a sensor
that i got for 40 bucks or whatever
that's on z-wave so that goes ahead and
can turn on motion activated so you want
your lights in your living room to turn
on when it gets too dark there you go
you can check the luminance to make sure
it's below sorts a thing when the motion
goes off if the lights are off the
lights can go on if as it happened in
three minutes to go back off again this
is really simple basic stuff to throw
together if you have a plex or something
and you want to make sure to many people
aren't watching all of your wonderful
DVDs that you ripped yourself of course
you can check that too it pulls in all
the information one spot for you if you
want to get super fancy because it's you
know that's too boring it's too easy
right no no no you want to run in flux
DB
you want to collect all your metrics and
start getting serious with your data you
can do it there's an influx DB reporting
plugin you can then make your graph on a
grass because why should the things you
learn at work stay there bring them home
now you know where your kitchen
temperature is all day long so there's a
whole bunch of possibilities here you
can have your own nagios or pagerduty
for your home right what's going on
there they have it plugged in so you can
easily set up a little automation maybe
some motion happens it sends you a push
notification or SMS text message no
problem you can graph your own metrics
of your house activity never know
interesting things happen get set up
your automations to trigger things
here's a fun one many people don't think
about you have flux and you have all
these things for your devices so they
stop emitting blue light at night
philips hue lights can actually go
softer you can change the spectrum that
they emit you can set up flux for your
home they actually have a plug-in and
component that does this when it gets
later in the evening it starts changing
the hue of all the lights that you set
up for it that's kind of cool stuff so
there's a whole bunch more of these
there's an entire list of all in the
cookbook as a whole bunch of components
I'm not going to go through them there's
too many there's like nine hundred of
these the community has been very busy
integrating with everything maybe next
time in a part two we can go over how
the home assistant core functions
scheduling component callbacks this is
all the Python 3 stuff but this isn't a
full talk utility of Python 3 type hints
the code base has a whole bunch of these
throughout it if you haven't used them
before they're very very handy good
tools like pycharm can start telling you
when you've used methods that don't
exist on an object because your tool
knows what the object actually is I we
got we could go over handling a sinker
routine listeners versus blocking with
red pools we have all these different
libraries that are talking to each other
when you automate these things some of
them want to actually go to the Internet
some don't but they block that comes up
so whole bunch of neat things you can do
if anybody thought it was all about
doing clever things like turning on your
thermostat or making alarms go off
hopefully you know that there's a lot
more that you can do with this now
that's it thank you